one of the best in the business when he
used to play regularly and he comes off
the couch
after missing two years of football
to fill in for the rams and then it was
more than just a fill in he was a
dynamite crucial member of this super
bowl running team now a super bowl
champion eric weddle here on the rich
eisen show how you doing eric weddle
rich my man
uh
man
super bowl champ bro super bowl champs
yeah super bowl champ all right i i
don't even know how to start with you
but i'll just start with
when did you get the phone call from the
rams who called you who called you from
the rams eric raheem rahim called me i
was in i was in a meeting with the with
a local high school about taking over
maybe in the future their football
program and
i i came out and had a had a missed call
from raheem in the text and i said hey
dub give me a call when you get this and
so
my first initial thought was like
i'm not sure what help i can do
uh for the for the playoff game against
the
against the cardinals i mean i haven't
played against them in a couple years i
don't know what scouting i could do for
them
uh you know this was tuesday of game
week and uh i called him back
and he was like hey what you doing we're
just chopping it up and then he just got
straight too he's like hey you're not
fat and out of shape are you and i said
i said of course not of course not but
what uh what's going on and so
from there on he he laid down what his
what they had this crazy idea about me
coming back and
helping them out they were in dire need
and uh after a few hours of talking to
other coaches and players and
thinking it through i said shoot why not
man this is a second chance of a
lifetime and i'd regret i'd regret it if
i didn't
see you through
five weeks later super bowl champ
that is unbelievable so who did you who
did you talk to did you talk to mcveigh
did who else did you who else did you
speak to when you were considering and
other players yeah you talked to yeah so
i mean immediately when i got off the
phone with raheem i called chanel and
that's what my wife's name is and i uh
and i said
hey babe what would you say
what would you say if i told you monday
night i could be suiting up for the rams
and she said
she started laughing she said nice joke
what's really going on
i said no no for real uh
i just got the phone with raheem so i
talked to her
uh
you know when after going through all
the stuff she said hey babe if anyone
can do it you can and when she said that
i said you know what you're right like i
said i was on the fence really like
physically
i haven't done you know i work out but i
work out just to make my body feel
better and to
you know to stay in shape and you know
when you when you play for zones i have
it just becomes a part of you you know
working out and trying to stay healthy
and
do those things and and i was just like
i don't know you know and once she said
that i was like you know what you're
right like i look at myself as one of
the most mentally toughest guys in this
world and
if anyone can do it i could so then i
circled back with a couple other coaches
then i last
talked to sean about three probably
three hours later after the initial call
you know when raheem called around 3 30
probably circled back to sean around
seven
and uh you know he was all on board with
it and and then uh
you know by about 9 30 decided to roll
i got up there about 1 a.m and was in
the building by 5 30 getting to work
this is unbelievable you cannot make it
up eric weddle you cannot make up what
you're saying right now because you also
played expertly you like you you play i
mean you you
how many did you play 60 snaps uh
against uh the the niners did you in the
championship game is that did you work
your way up to like 60 defensive snaps
eric
yeah yeah i mean uh
first week i played 19 right against the
cardinals and luckily we were blowing
them out right in the second half
because i actually i actually aggravated
my hammy and growing in that game so i
it would have been
i would have went back in there but i
probably would have tore everything and
that would have been the end of this
special run
uh but thankfully we didn't and then the
next week
uh
i played 61 snaps against tampa
and then played played everything played
every started and played everything the
nfc championship in the super bowl what
did brady say to you when he saw you in
that game did he say something to you
eric
yeah he was you know i just wanted to
you know
show my respect to him after the game
and and let him know how much i admire
him and look up to him and he was just
like dude you got to be sora's you know
what
we just talked back and forth a little
bit and
just what a you know he's the goat and
uh just wanted to let him know that he
inspired me from afar
well maybe you might inspire him to come
back eric i don't know
you know
i don't know i don't know about that i
mean it's just crazy a lot of things had
to align right both safeties had to go
down
uh they had no depth behind that uh
and
you know they knew me they knew that i
would be in somewhat good enough shape
to even try it
right i could have fallen fat in my face
the two practices before monday night
but that wasn't going to happen i mean
i'm i'm
i can go out there and give them a few
snaps
but to build and to make it what it was
to start in the super bowl and to have
an impact that i did and to help these
guys
was something that i'll cherish for the
rest of my life and hopefully people see
that when an opportunity comes across
hopefully you're ready for it and you
and you're and you're ready right
because
an opportunity of a lifetime came to me
and even though i wasn't 100 ready i
took the chance and look what happened
i'm a super bowl champ now eric weddle
here on the rich eisen show ninth years
with san diego and the chargers and then
three with baltimore and then your last
one with the rams you retire you know we
chatted after you retired and now here
you are champion with the rams after
that story you just told what was super
sunday like for you was it what you
dreamt about
eric
it was incredible it was really uh
you know the game itself the flows the
ups and downs the adversity
uh everything that
you feel a football game uh is and and
was from a player's standpoint you never
really realize all the all the other
i wouldn't say bs but just as a player
like the timeouts were so long the
halftime show like the rock getting up
there and doing the thing that's like
are we
the show or is everything else the show
it was
it was just it was just like kind of
like hey we had 40 minutes before we
left the field like why not do all this
stuff during that time instead of having
a 40-minute countdown then have all
these other things going on then the
rock gets up there when zero's on the
clock we're supposed to go and then he's
going for another five minutes it's like
holy smokes but
uh you know i know i know it's a
spectacle for the world and this and
that but
uh when the game was being played when
we weren't staying around on timeouts
and everything else it was incredible
and and then
being a part of the last play and
watching it unfold
right before my own eyes and live action
was was something that i can literally
be in that moment for the rest of my
life
go ahead no before we get to that though
i do want to i'm sorry i don't want to
just hop in here when did you tear your
pec though when did that happen eric
that was in the it was in the first
quarter uh
it was just you know i rewatched the
play that night when i got the game film
and and i first initially thought like i
thought joe mixon just kicked me or or
or stepped on me
because it was like i just didn't know
i'm like how in the world
is my shoulder peck hurting so bad so
then i rewatched it and it was actually
my teammate
was running behind him and he kicked my
arm as i was tackling them so it was
just
and it went the opposite direction which
is just so crazy and unfortunate
you know what are the odds of that
happening but yeah i just
i was in a lot of pain but i'm like this
is a super bowl man i can run i can
still talk and communicate
uh yeah is it gonna hurt every second
yeah but i got 50 years to rehab this
thing and
go get surgery and do what i need to do
but as long as i wasn't a liability out
there i wasn't going to be i wasn't
going to come off that field not in that
moment not when i've
dreamt of this situation i was like i'm
not going out like this so you eric you
just better clutch up get your mind
right and tough it up that's your your
rod you're on your right side right
because we're we're seeing you
tackle jamar chase with one left arm
right here on our screen you know like
that so that's what you're one left arm
tackler the rest of the day then pretty
much right is that it yeah yeah i mean
just
you know i
just throwing the whole body in there
whatever it took you know a few times i
just threw my body in there and
oh you know hopefully when i looked up
that the guy was tackled
you know
in that moment you're just whatever and
then sometimes you just had to you had
to throw your your right arm in there
and
and just get through it the pain the
pain was uh
you got used to it after a while and uh
you know it's bigger than that it's
bigger than myself this this was about
the moment right the moment
of what are you gonna do and are you
gonna are you gonna clutch up mind over
matter and help your team win
by any means necessary or you are you
not and for me it was it wasn't even a
question it was like hey
let's go do this let's get this win and
be immortalized in the history books for
the rest of our lives few more minutes
left here with super bowl champion eric
weddle of the los angeles rams the
tuesday after super bowl 56 here on the
rich eisen show let's get to the last
defensive snap for you uh in the game
and in your career um
walk me through fourth and short with
time winding down in super bowl 56 eric
walk me through that one yeah so we're
coming out we have uh we're playing
man-to-man i was on number three tyler
boyd and uh we have low hull help so the
way we play that
you know any type of shallower in cut uh
you know t-rap was in inside of me so
he'll he'll overtake that and then i
flashed the second window and as they
came out in the formation we knew who
the running back was mixon wasn't in
there so
they ain't running the ball especially
getting stuff done third and one
uh and then you hear the checks you hear
all the things you studied throughout
the week and you feel like it's going to
be passed and you know ad talked a lot
about that uh after the game where he
got such a great jump off the ball knew
and knowing that uh it was passed and he
had he had his best pass rush move ready
and for us on the back end i mean it was
we we had that locked down the route
combination and the concept was there
wasn't anywhere to throw the ball
anyways uh so whether it was a.d gonna
get to him or someone else he he was
gonna have to joe is gonna have to make
something happen because so the first
reads the second reading the third read
weren't there and we had it all gloved
up so i flashed to the second window the
slant was right there from the outside
by number one uh and at that point he
was getting hit by a.d and then it was
like oh my gosh
you're just you're just thinking
yourself this is gonna happen
it's happening the ball flop falls in
you know throws it up in the air just
trying to make something happen and it
hit the ground and in that moment you
know
you're a super bowl champ there's one
timeout they they have nothing left
we're going to take a knee and the
energy the passion the just to celebrate
with your teammates
is like nothing you'll ever be a part of
the rest of your life that that moment
is something uh that you dream of and to
be able to live it and to be able to be
in my situation five weeks ago to now
when i thought that dream was over
uh i'm just super
super humbled and
fortunate and blessed to be have that
moment in my life for the for the for
the history books i was a part of that
play to win the super bowl damn straight
you were eric weddle how good is aaron
donald i mean like like like what i mean
i know right i mean people
people don't uh
kind of take for granted what he is and
what he's all about right and
it's just it's hard to fathom
if he ever
ever got just single blocks
the majority of a game what would happen
i mean literally he gets the he gets the
offensive line rotation to him every
time it's like literally and when he
doesn't it's a sack or it's a tfl or
it's a it's a hit on the qb i mean
that's how great he is and i play with a
lot of great players but he's by far the
best player i've ever played with
at any position
and it's uh
he just does so much for our team our
defense uh the success other guys have
because of him
and the attention that he gets goes
unsaid but i mean geez the the
individual accolades
are second to none he's he's an even
better teammate better better man uh
he's one of one of one when i say 101
there is no other a.d there will never
be another ad
and uh we just got to appreciate his
agreement well i mean and while we're on
the subject you're hard to fathom it's
hard to fathom that he'd he'd walk away
at age 30 at the top of his game
like this you know what a a player who's
thinking of retiring or knows it's time
to retire looks like you used to be one
and you are now one again
uh
what do you think do you think that he's
that this is really something he's
thinking about or or could happen
eric yeah i mean i don't i'm not i'm not
100 sure i just know when
it gets to the point where
you can't do what you normally do
physically
it becomes draining right mentally
you have to do so much to keep yourself
at the level that you expect of yourself
right and when you're not able to
practice every day when you're not able
to lift every day and do what you love
to do
because your body is just hurting or
your body is breaking down it takes a
toll on you so i don't know
how
if he that's how it was for me and i
just felt that i mentally couldn't keep
up with it it's the same thing that tom
talked about when he retired if you're
not 100
committed mentally to doing everything
that this job entails then you just
can't do it you just can't do it so you
need it you just gotta go you gotta step
away and for him i don't know
uh that that'll be for him to decide i
think
getting away from the game getting away
letting your body fully recover and and
you know do i think he will i don't
think so
uh but
you understand it if so as a player i
totally get it if he's ready and if his
mind's not in it and he's tired of
everything that he is that it implies of
being great uh i totally get it so we
shall see
i'd probably be the last one to figure
it out but uh hopefully uh more great
great days ahead of him but if it is i
mean
he's one of the all-time greats man and
uh
everyone should applaud what he's done
so far and i know i do and the couple
minutes i have left with you eric weddle
i just want to know what it was like for
some of these hugs these super bowl post
super bowl winning hugs what was it like
with raheem morris the defensive
coordinator who called you on that day
what did what do you say to this guy
when the journey's complete in the
ultimate way like that what do you say
what was that like
it was you know we just uh
you know he coached me at the senior
bowl
15 years ago 16 years ago whatever it
was and we always talked about having a
chance to be on the same side right
whether he coached me
at some point in our careers and to have
it come full circle in this moment
is just so special for him and i and
he's going to be a head coach one day
and hopefully win super bowl
he has just has that it back there he
knows how to relate to the players he
knows how to connect to us his even
killed demeanor is so much like me as a
player so we just connect on another
level and being able to talk ball talk
shop
i'm just so happy for him i'm grateful
that he
even thought
of the idea to bring me back him and
coach e
uh
it's just i'm forever embedded to him
right because he gave me a chance to
live a second life as a kid when no one
gets this chance right you're retired
for two years you you don't get a chance
like this and i owe that i owe the super
bowl ring for him
uh for giving me this chance to have a
role on this team and and and taking it
and running with it so we'll be forever
connected that's what we talk about
we'll we're forever connected in this
life as super bowl chance and doing
something that nobody has done and
probably will never do again of doing
what we did uh coming out of retirement
and making uh making a splash
what was it a hug with uh stafford like
you know another guy a long time veteran
in the league who's now got that ring
like you eric what about that one
yeah man you know we just it was just a
moment you know we wanted this so much
for each other you know i wasn't a part
of this season the whole team yeah you
know the whole season obviously but i
watched every game i watched every play
so i felt emotionally i was attached to
them
and uh watching his career from afar and
then being a teammate for the last five
weeks and just growing appreciation of
how hard he works and and the command
and the ownership and
just he is he is a quarterback through
and through what you want right uh how
he owns it how he how he stands on the
table for what he wants to do what he
does and how he challenges his coaches
how he challenges his players and
expects greatness
uh
and it was just in that moment we were
just uh
you know saying how much of this moment
we did for each other right how he
wanted to do it for whit wanted to do it
for a.d wanted to do it for myself and
vice versa and that was what was so
special about this group of men man we
wanted to do it for each other it wasn't
so much about doing it for myself it was
about having this chance to do it for
for the guys that have been in the
league for so long and done so much
but now we're here and we can sit here
and say we're super chance because we
did it for each other not for ourselves
and then uh lastly with your wife who's
been with you this entire journey
what was that hug like um
eric what was that moment like if you
don't mind me uh asking yeah
it was it was emotional it was uh
you know i wouldn't be here without her
uh over the course you know we've been
married coming up on 17 years we got
married in college she's been in there
been through the grind and only the
wives know of the nfl what it l what
it's like
of not having their husbands home for
six seven months at a time
and being able to support and encourage
and be that person that is always there
for you
uh on the ups and downs uh she is one of
a kind she was the rock is the rock of
our family and held us together
and
uh in that moment i mean we're still in
awe we're still in shock that this
actually happened
and uh for her to support me and really
when she said anybody nobody could do it
but but me i mean she was the one that
gave me the confidence to go try this
she really was and she's been there and
i just hope that
uh over the next 50 odd years that i'm
you know i think i'm going to live till
i'm 100 so i'm going to say 67.
that i could that i could give her the
attention and
serve and sacrifice with her and the
kids as much as she did for me because
it was second to none eric weddle you
have always been one of my favorites
when i heard you were coming out of
retirement with the rams i'm like you've
got to be kidding me and
now that that whole sense of you gotta
be kidding me is off the charts you're a
super bowl champion
what an unbelievable ending a fairy tale
that nobody saw coming
thanks for the time and sharon you're
really one of my faves congrats you
deserve it rich rich love you bro
and uh super bowl chance i'm in the club
finally you are in indonesia you're in
the club you're in the club yes indeed
we have we have a club right here as a
matter of fact that you're allowed into
any time any time eric enjoy the parade
have a good time i will take care of
yourself brother you bet you be well the
one and only
eric weddle so awesome super bowl
champion what a story
the ultimate rise and shine
brought to you by courtyard by marriott
as the official hotel of the nfl for 11
years in county courtyard by marriott is
proud to fuel your love of the game all
season long when you're on the road no
reason to miss out on watching the game
you can meet us at the bistro bar to
cheer on your favorite team with good
food and good company if you're
traveling to an out of town game with
over a thousand hotels across the u.s
courtyard's got the perfect place for
you to stay near the stadium and if
you're a marriott bonvoy member discover
even more ways to earn and redeem points
with access to exclusive nfl experiences
at courtyard by marriott passion moves
us forward where will yours
take you
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here